welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am of course not David Pakman I'm
Benjamin Dixon you can find all of my
work at the Benjamin Dixon show com I
actually want you to go and register for
my newsletter which i think is the most
efficient newsletter I only hit your
inbox when an issue is very important
and I hit you with three bullet points
so that you can get a very succinct
breakdown of the propaganda that's being
thrown your way it's called to the point
and I get to the point and three bullet
points are not or less go to the
Benjamin Dixon show calm and register
for that let's get to the point Fox News
is in a panic because more and more
frequently people are confirming the
fact that Donald Trump is unstable and
not fit for office and evoking the 25th
amendment amendment last night they put
on this clip of a woman who said a woman
who happens to work for President Trump
but that's in the fine print in the
lower third at the bottom of the video
but listen to her and she said she has
scientific evidence that President Trump
is the most stable president in history
yeah Trump derangement syndrome I mean
Shawn that's what most people have
called it to this point but my book
actually uses science and real data and
true psychological theory to explain why
it is quite possible that this president
is the most sound minded person to ever
occupy the White House just you eat
literally liberals hands are gonna
explode at what you say the madness is
just watching them go crazy over the
fact that he's really pretty unfazed by
them now normally I would I would
relegate this to the trash heap of
low-hanging fruit but I think that this
is significant in its own way yeah it's
significant because it is a consistent
game that's being played by a
conservative media they take something
that is obvious something that everyone
can see clearly and they will without
hesitation put up someone give them a
label as an expert claim that they're
using data
claim that they're only representing the
facts and the facts don't care about
your feelings kind of thing and they
will throw the most ridiculous notions
out across the airwaves repeat it in the
blogosphere repeated on social media and
all of a sudden you've taken something
that is ridiculous as I have the most
scientific data that Donald Trump is the
most sound president that we've had and
you just have it solidified not in the
minds of anyone else except for their
conservative bubble that's what this is
about this isn't really about trying to
make the case of Donald Trump as sound
this is about solidifying their
hermetically sealed echo chamber so that
nobody in that echo chamber could ever
come up for air to think an intelligent
thought on their own because they have
been systematically dumb down by
conservative media that's really what
this video that's the only thing that's
relevant about this video is that it
just shows you the extent to which they
are willing to go and actually I can
rephrase this there is no limit to what
they're willing to do to preserve their
grip on power and they cannot preserve
their grip on power unless they
absolutely wipe out any doubt in the
minds of their sycophants of their
supporters that base 36% that will never
leave nor forsake if I could use
religious rhetoric but they would never
leave or forsake Donald Trump that's
because they are given and they are fed
a relentless supply of right-wing
propaganda so much so that they can be
convinced that the sky is green and that
the grass is blue that is how effective
this propaganda is and Fox News is just
one of the many outlets that carry out
these orders on a regular basis and it
spills over to all these
pseudo-intellectual voices of the
intellectual dark web their job is to do
the same
it is to intellectualize either outright
stupidity or to intellectualize bigotry
but it's all in efforts
creating this hermetically sealed echo
chamber that self reinforces their own
lies and then gives them cover for their
bigotry by making it seem are not even
making it seem but by actually saying
hey look at all of these people look at
all these people who follow jordan
peterson as he suggests all of the
ridiculous and sexist things that he
suggests look at all these people who
who who follow ben shapiro
as he presents all of his straw men as
some type of true intellectual challenge
that oh I'm really taking down this
ridiculous straw man that I pulled out
of the air that absolutely no one ever
said right they create these worlds that
their supporters can exist in and have
reinforcements and to have confirmation
and to have no exposure to anything
except the dogma and propaganda of
conservatism there is nothing like that
on the left we would argue that we don't
want anything like that on the left but
the fact of the matter is if we don't
have a counterbalance not by replicating
the propaganda hermetically sealed
echo chamber but but by amplifying the
truth I say like this they've weaponized
lies on the right we have to weaponize
truth on the left